nice to see you uh congrats on season
two I watched the whole thing over the
weekend it's another fantastic season
um uh I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning uh if if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why oh yeah I'd watch
this I think um I should probably say
this
I I probably shouldn't plug other things
that I've done
um but yeah I I would I would recommend
this yeah whatever the last thing I did
was that's what I'd recommend because
hopefully I'm learning as I go along so
definitely this
Gary plug JFK
oh Gary was in oh my gorgeous he was
Leo's world
of course
yeah yeah
film if I was in that film yeah that guy
knows his way around the camera yeah
he's gonna land down his feet um yeah
you were making you never know how
Something's Gonna actually turn out when
you were making season one and filming
season two
um did you have a really good feeling
about the show as you were making it
because it ended up being both um
critically well received and audiences
loved it yeah I mean the all the
ingredients in this you know we we
should
uh we didn't want to take them for
granted but we'd really have to try our
hardest to mess it up and and um
thankfully we didn't I think uh we knew
that we were making something that
people would enjoy for sure it's
definitely entertaining
um
and I think you know the more the more
that we have of that at the moment the
better
um but no I I kind of I kind of knew
that it would be really good I hoped it
would be as good as it's
it's ended up but um we kind of knew
when you've got that past and the the
material is just so fantastic yeah in
season two Gary is eating a lot there's
a lot of scenes involving him in food
when you were reading the scripts where
you like thank God this is not me uh no
because I'm normally the guy that has to
sit there whilst he's doing it so
it makes it it's hard it's a hell of a
challenge I'm doing a sort of four or
five page scene with a man that's eaten
um an inhuman amount of noodles
so uh yeah but I I just know that it's
so funny on the on the paper it's just
like you read this normal scene but then
you add on the fact that oh by the way
he's devouring a huge bowl of of noodles
at the same time so uh no I love it I
love it when he does things like that
but Gary I don't know Gary's gonna be
huge if we keep shooting this You're
Gonna Roll We're Gonna Roll him into
scenes
um yeah on like a skateboard Gary told
me that he he he hates when people are
in movies or TV and they're pretending
to eat he said it's a real thing with
him and he said he has to eat when he's
filming so as a as the as the person
who's doing scenes with him did you feel
more pressure on yourself to not [ __ ] up
any takes because he's really eating in
every take
no I would purposely
I purposely [ __ ] up
um so that he could eat have to eat more
noodles
um yeah to just watch him slowly bloat
and inflate like that like James and the
Giant Peach yeah I've seen all of season
two but I'm not sure what you want to
tell people about it
um what have you been telling friends
and family about the second season
well it's difficult because we're
shooting the third one right now
um and so it's just a bit of of a mind
game as to go back to what is it that's
actually in season two so it's been
quite fun to sort of revisit it all just
now
um I I what I've been saying is that it
gets a lot more dangerous the stakes are
a lot higher in terms of what the
problem is in this one
um it is certainly more dangerous
um but it it still has that brilliant
sort of M25 kind of home county
englishness that I really love that um
that is very unusual to see in anything
about Espionage
um but it's definitely a lot more
dangerous yeah what's interesting about
season two is that um you have a you're
basically a better relationship with uh
with lamb you know I mean I think he
trusts you a little bit more but but
still doesn't really trust you but you
know what I mean
yeah I think he's he definitely he just
enjoys writing reverse so much and I
think um whenever everybody's probably
had a boss like that and when you
realize that's what they enjoy you also
work out ways to sort of cope with that
um and as long as you don't break
uh they it seems to sort of piss them
off even more and so there's this it's
building in building which is I hope I
do hope dramatically that one day it
does break one of them snaps
um but at the moment it's really
wonderful to play that sort of simmering
tension
um that he can do anything he wants to
me but I'm not going to break because
that's the one thing you want so um yeah
and and I mean that's where the noodles
come in as well I think it's all part of
sort of playing and toying with with
River
um I I wouldn't put it past lamb that he
knew River was going to come into that
scene and was had already eaten and
purposely ordered a big bowl of noodles
just to sort of really mess with River
um you mentioned season three uh Gary
also said you guys were filming season
three
um how nice is it uh uh because you got
picked up for season three and four you
know very quickly which is fantastic
um what has been like uh working on
season three and what can you tease
people about it I mean it's been it's
been a whirlwind to be honest
um because the rate at which they can
put these things out now is um it's just
gone it's it's it's a hell of
it's so quick so in terms of what I can
tell you about Seton three I can't
really tell you anything obviously
because someone will jump out from
behind that screen over there
and knock me out
um but
it you know
it definitely if you know the books it
definitely follows the books so it is
out there in a way you can go find out
you don't need to ask me you could go
and read the book but
um
the relationships develop
and keep developing and from River's
point of view with his grandfather and
with lamb and those relationships they
keep building to a really interesting
place
um but I cannot tell you anything no the
thing that's great about the show is
it's not like CGI it's basically you
know it's all practical which is one of
the reasons why you guys can film it so
quickly and get it on you know Apple TV
um I believe there's now seven books are
you or soon to be seven books do you
feel like
um you could be doing this I guess are
you looking forward to possibly spending
more time you know what I mean like I
wouldn't be surprised if five and six
get greenlit pretty soon I mean I would
like we would love the world of this is
such is such a joy
um and it definitely feels like a
one-off and the atmosphere of it and the
materials so I mean as long as it's
still interesting and people are still
interested I think it's the same with
anything I'd love to do it
um you know want to do it until I'm like
60
um I don't I doubt that River makes 50 I
would feel I can't imagine him as a 50
year old
until someone actually said recently
which I think is quite interesting is
does he eventually end up turning into
lamb there's just like bits of his hair
just start becoming more scraggly his
shirts become more stained and slowly
just sinks into lamb right I mean I
quite enjoy that uh my last question for
you because I'm almost out of time I'm
really looking forward to the gold which
is based on a crazy true story
um what I'm assuming you've wrapped on
that what can you tell people about it
because it's it has a great All-Star
guest
yeah it's another great yeah it's it's
really fantastic to be part of these
things
um and be surrounded by a great company
of actors
um that yeah we wrap that uh April
um and um I'm only just now managing to
get back down from the weight that I had
to put on for it which was uh which is
always hellish to do but um
it's this the story of it is just a
completely incredible
um and far-reaching and still feeling
consequences of it today uh and uh and I
I I'm so excited for people to see that
I really am and it's very different to
this and which is always a wonderful
thing as an actor yeah on that note I'm
just going to say congrats on everything
and uh I you know I'm really happy uh
slow horses is fantastic thank you for
your work thank you so much thanks again